نذكر بتطورات الموقف على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه فقد قال مراسل الجزيره ان
قذائف هاون باتجاه بلده المطله المتاخمه
للحدود اللبنانيه قد تمت تم اطلاقها وانا
رئيس مجلس المطله قد طلب من الاسرائيليين
البقاء في الملاجئ بعد تعرض البلده لقصف
لقذائف الهاون ياتي ذلك بعدما اكد الجيش
الايطالي اعترضا 25 صاروخا من اصل 34
اطلقت من لبنان على شمال اسرائيل وذكرت
هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان معظم الصواريخ
التي لطقت من لبنان من طرازي كاتيوشا
وجراده واعلنت فرق الاسعاف اصابه ثلاثه
اسرائيليين في القصر كما قررتها السلطات
فتح الملاجئ في جميع البلدات المتاخمه
للحدود مع لبنان
الى ذلك اكد مراسل الجزيره اغلاق المجال
الجوي الشماليه اسرائيل امام حركه الطيران
البدني من جانبه تراس رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو اجتماعا لهيئه
اركان الجيش لدراسه الرد على الهجوم
الصاروقي من لبنان بينما قال وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه ان تل ابيب ستتخذ
جميع الاجراءات اللازمه للدفاع عن امنها
هذا ونقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصدر الامنيه
اللبنانيه تاكيده عدم تسجيل اي قصف
اسرائيلي على الاراضي اللبنانيه من جانبها
قله القوات الدوليه العامله في جنوب لبنان
يونيفيل انها رصدت اطلاق مجموعه من
الصواريخ باتجاه اسرائيل اضافه ان الوضع
الحالي خطير وحتى جميع الاطراف على ضبط
النفسي وتجنب التصعيد
هذه هي الروايه رسميه اللبنانيه جاءت على
لسان الجيش اللبنانيه الذي اعلنا انه تم
اطلاق عدد من الصواريخ من محيط بلدات
القليله
والمعليه وزبقين واكد الجيش تسير دوريات
بالتعاون مع قوات حفظ السلام اليونيفيل
واكدت من جانبها الخارجيه اللبنانيه ان
لبنان مستعد للتعاون مع اليونيفيل واتخاذ
الاجراءات المناسبه لعوده الهدوء
والاستقرار
وقد حذرت الخارجيه اللبنانيه من نيات
اسرائيل الصعيديه التي تهدد السلم والامن
الاقليمين والدوليين وقالت انها لبنان
يؤكده مجددا كامل احترامه والتزامه بقرار
مجلس الامن الدولي
1701 وشددت على حصن لبنان على الهدوء
والاستقرار وانه يدعو المجتمع الدولي
للضغط على اسرائيل لوقف التصعيد